reisen nach new york st moritz korsika
dazu eine aktienoption und ein
aufsichtsratsmandat hat sich der cdu
abgeordnete philipp am tor für diese
vergünstigungen nach allem was bisher
bekannt ist als türöffner für ein
amerikanisches startup betätigt und eine
vielversprechende politische karriere
aufs spiel gesetzt
jedenfalls wirft dies ein schlaglicht
auf die dunkel zone in der sich politik
und lobbyismus aller art weitgehend
unbeobachtet und unkontrolliert begegnen
der fall am tor
wie viel optimismus darf es sein jetzt
in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde herzlich willkommen bei
uns liebe zuschauer meine gäste zunächst
hier im studio ghana schimke ist bei uns
mitglied im vorstand der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion fabia demasi
ist stellvertretender vorsitzender der
fraktion die linke im deutschen
bundestag
zugeschaltet karl jurka politikberater
und freier lobbyist hier in berlin und
mein kollege paul ronzheimer der
stellvertretende chefredakteur der bild
-zeitung willkommen bei uns frau schimke
philipp am tor nimmt er die vorwürfe
vielleicht doch zu sehr auf die leichte
schulter er hat ja einen fehler
eingestanden aber sonst schweigt er
beharrlich ist das gut
also zunächst einmal wird das was
geschehen ist was zurzeit diskutiert
wird geprüft und die frage ist ja nicht
ob korsika oder new york sondern die
frage ist ob hier ein rechtlicher
verstoß vorgelegen hat und nimmt es in
keinem fall auf die leichte schulter ich
glaube er geht sehr sehr tief in sich er
ist sehr sehr nachdenklich und ich hoffe
ja dass ich das alles bald klärt dass es
sich aufklärt und dass wir uns gehen auf
die sache konzentrieren auch selbst dazu
befragen er hat uns mitgeteilt dass er
im moment auf öffentlichkeitswirksame
auftritte will ich erstmal verzichten
will hat er sie am tor hat ja seine
nebentätigkeit für dieses start-up
augustus intelligence angegeben die
aktienoptionen bekommen hat musste er
nicht angeben weil die sind ja gar nicht
fällig geworden die müssen erst dann
gegeben werden wenn kapital zufließt ist
also nicht so sehr am tor das problem
sondern die tatsache dass es hier
einfach an regeln fehlt und dort wo sie
bestehen auch sanktionen gibt es ja dass
sie einfach nicht angewendet werden
ja beides denn es ist schon eine große
instinktlosigkeit gerade auch jetzt in
der kroner krise wo viele menschen um
ihren job bangen
dort den eindruck entstehen zu lassen
dass politische entscheidungen auch
käuflich sein könnten aber wo sie
absolut recht haben ist der bundestag
muss dafür sorgen dass es hier klare
regeln gibt
und aktienoptionen die sind dafür da
dass man in der zukunft einen vorteil
hat und deswegen sollte das auch
zukünftig öffentlich sein
also auch wenn sie schon entstehen und
nicht erst wenn sie ausbezahlt werden
absolut denn ich denke es ist normal
dass lobbyismus gibt auch umweltverbände
gewerkschaften machen lobbyismus aber es
darf nicht der eindruck entstehen dass
man sich politische entscheidung kaufen
kann und deswegen haben die bürgerinnen
und bürger in anspruch darauf zu wissen
auf welcher gehaltsliste man dort steht
ja yorker hat sie lieb am tor eigentlich
die sogenannte rote linie überschritten
die man als politiker nicht
überschreiten sollte oder auch nicht
überschreiten darf
ich finde die überschritten wenn wir im
grunde genommen
entweder politiker ohne not least sein
können aber beides zusammen geht nicht
das ist ein absolutes no go
und das muss schon festgehalten werden
es handelt sich um terrorismus und um
eine politik skandal wenn es ein skandal
ist das muss wie die verschämt gesagt
hat und das tat er aber das geht nicht
und das ist ein neuerlicher fall wo die
medien von einem lobbyismus skandal
sprechen und die wahrheit ist ein
politischer skandal er uns aber es gab
ja ziemlich großes kopfschütteln über
das verhalten von philippe am tor
die frage wie kommt es jetzt dazu da
eine viel versprechende politische
karriere vielleicht aufs spiel zu setzen
woran liegt das liegt das daran dass
politiker so sehr in einer filter blase
leben das manchen das gespür für das
zulässige für das vernünftige abhanden
gekommen ist
was meinen sie ja ganz offensichtlich
ist das so denn wenn man sich auf der
einen seite anschaut wie sich philipp
amthor auch in talkshows geriert hat es
gibt da diese sequenz wollte zum
beispiel sagt dass er eine tafel
schokolade uns den euro gar nicht
annehmen dürfe also sich sozusagen als
der saubermann der politik oder
zumindest der union dort dargestellt hat
aber eben in wahrheit dann offen
wahlweise teure privatflüge angenommen
hat es ist auch völlig unklar was genau
er denn jetzt für diese firma gemacht
hat denn darauf antwortet er nicht er
verweigert die auskunft nicht nur
gegenüber dem spiegel sondern auch
gegenüber und der bild zeitung und
anderen medien die ihn dazu befragen er
möchte nicht dass weitere details
rauskommen und ich muss da der
verschenken widersprechen es geht eben
nicht nur darum ob das ganze
strafrechtlich relevant war ja oder nein
sondern es geht hier um die frage auch
des politischen anstands und den hat er
am tor vermissen lassen denn wenn jemand
auf einem bundestags papier für eine
firma wirbt für ein treffen wirbt mit
dem wirtschaftsministerium und er dann
von dieser firma eingeladen wird dann
ist das ein problem
stichwort dieser das unrechtsbewusstsein
dass nicht alles was legal ist ist auch
legitim das ist steckt er jetzt hinter
der dem was die wir in großer anzahl
gerade gesagt hat jetzt will ja
offensichtlich die fraktionsführung auch
philipp am tor ins kreuzverhör nehmen
was glauben sie was die wir die die
fraktionsführung reagieren oder was
denken sie was jetzt passiert mit ihm
gehen natürlich sachlich mit diesem
vorgang um ohne frage
und insofern bleibt es jetzt erst mal
abzuwarten was die prüfung durch den
deutschen bundestag herausbringt aber
ich gebe natürlich an ronzheimer recht
es geht natürlich nicht um die frage ist
jetzt hier rechtlich ein verstoß
vorgenommen worden sondern auch wo liegt
das menschliche versagen und der punkt
ist der wir sind alles menschen
wir sind alle menschen in allen
fraktionen und überall werden fehler
gemacht und das wird auch immer wieder
passieren und ist doch völlig egal was
wir für änderungen beschließen im
abgeordnetengesetz in den
verhaltensregeln
sowas kann und wird immer wieder
passieren und deswegen warne ich davor
und ich kritisiere dass auch zugleich
dass das jetzt wieder als auftakt
genommen wird um ein altes pferd zu
reiten um alte forderungen erneut
aufzubringen
die aber in der sache überhaupt nicht
ändern gut also mit dem alten pferd zu
reiten dann gleich sehen was damit
möglicherweise gemeint ist aber noch mal
das geht auch nicht hier ein
generalverdacht politiker hierauf zu
machen dass ich mir selbst gesagt das
wird immer wieder vorkommen trotzdem
gilt es diesen generalverdacht zu
vermeiden
herr j wenn wir so etwas ja nicht der
erste fall in der politik wenn wenn das
passiert ist da gibt es daher zu wenig
unrechtsbewusstsein bei manchen
politiker ja das team und immer wenn er
anschließend den ich recht gebe das
problem ist ich kann nicht juristisch
einschätzen aber eine intervention für
eine firma die dafür zahlt auch
bundesschatzbriefen hier ist missbrauch
ob sie juristisch missbrauch ist das
sollen andere klären
politisch ist das missbrauch was geht
ich erinnere mich an den verein sehr
prominenten deutschen botschafters der
auf dem briefpapier der deutschen
botschaft etwas geschrieben hat was eine
intervention für einen privaten zweck
war der mann wurde bitte sofort
entlassen vom auswärtigen amt und es
waren alle der meinung dass es richtig
ist dass das auswärtige amt entlassen
hat auch dort wurden nie geklärt ob
solistisch ein bis bach war aber auch
prima wir botschaft das ist wie
bundesrepublik geht nicht und bringt man
mir des bundestags ist die
bundesrepublik geld nicht für die masse
ist am tor gestanden sie das bild jetzt
der berühmte tropfen der das fass zum
überlaufen bringt wird sich jetzt muss
ich jetzt etwas ändern
absolut und ich will der kollegin
explizit widersprechen ich denke schon
dass es einen unterschied macht ob zum
beispiel bekannt gewesen wäre dass er am
tor dort eben aktienoptionen hat
natürlich machen menschen fehler
wer ist frei von fehlern aber herr am
tor hat als er konfrontiert wurde mit
diesen vorwürfen zunächst nicht reagiert
er hat erst die aktienoptionen
zurückgegeben und sich aus dem
untersuchungsausschuss
attentat auf dem breitscheidplatz
zurückgezogen als ihm das durch die
presse auf die füße gefallen ist und von
daher glaube ich müssen wir hier
dringend handeln das ist ja nicht der
erste fall im bundestag wir hatten auch
schon fälle die den landesverband
mecklenburg vorpommern der cdu betreffen
mit karin strenz hier sind auch
sanktionen verhängt worden und der
europarat ein gremium des europarates
ein anti korruptions gremium hat
wiederholt gerügt dass die abgeordneten
bestechlichkeit aber auch eben die
transparenz unzureichend im bundestag
geregelt ist und es geht ja darum auch
die vielen anständigen kolleginnen und
kollegen zu schützen
ich kenne sehr viele kollegen in der
union die sind absolute
überzeugungstäter die sind nicht
käuflich und die muss man schützen
dadurch dass eben solche dinge nicht
mehr vorkommen herunter was meinen sie
wird das jetzt zu einer basis dieser
dieser tropfen der das fass zum
überlaufen bringt wird das jetzt zu
einer veränderung kommen ist der druck
der öffentliche druck jetzt auch so groß
dass der bundestag da vielleicht doch
ein lobbyregister beschließen wird
eigentlich hat man das ja im
koalitionsvertrag schon vereinbaren
wollen das ist dann wieder rausgekommen
aus dem koalitionsvertrag
jetzt ist dass die legislaturperiode ja
nur noch ein jahr im aber glauben sie
dass da noch was passiert auch um den
verdacht den da viele politiker auf sich
ziehen könnten da aus der öffentlichkeit
zu bringen
das ist sehr gut möglich und ich höre
auch aus der führung der union dass man
da sehr verärgert war das so zu sagen
dieser fall amthor diese diskussion
jetzt wieder auf die tagesordnung
gebracht hat man hatte eigentlich
gehofft dass das nicht kommen wird ich
kann mir vorstellen dass der druck jetzt
groß wird aber bevor wir sozusagen über
diese generelle frage sprechen
das lobbying ist das glaube ich ist es
noch mal wichtig zu betonen
das glaube ich eher amthor hier einen
fehler nach dem anderen machen es reiche
nicht zu sagen ja das war ein fehler
sondern er muss für aufklärung sorgen
und für diese aufklärung sorgt er nicht
er will geheim halten offenbar was dort
genau passiert ist er will nicht
auflisten mit welchen flügen er wohin
geflogen ist in welchen hotels
übernachtet hat
ich glaube dass seine wählerinnen und
wähler ein recht darauf haben zu
erfahren was herr am tor für diese firma
die ja auch wo es auch sehr viele offene
fragen gibt was denn eigentlich diese
firma wirklich macht das wird noch zu
klären sein aber im fall am tor wird
wichtig zu sein zu beantworten was hat
er jetzt getan und ich glaube da wird
man jetzt schauen was am freitag im
landesvorstand passiert ich denke er
wird sich noch weiteren gremien erklären
müssen und dann wird die frage sein wie
soll er damit umgehen jemand wie philipp
am tor der immer in bundestags reden und
wo er auftrat vor allem über recht und
ordnung gesprochen hat ich glaube das
wird sehr schwer für ihn sein
über diese themen weiterhin zu sprechen
wenn er selbst nicht bereit ist zu
erklären was er dort für wen getan
in dieser landesvorstandssitzung der cdu
mecklenburg vorpommern soll ja
möglicherweise auch über die kandidatur
zum parteivorsitzenden noch mal neu
entschieden dann verschenke ich will es
jetzt nochmal zu sagen zuspitzen zu
meine eingangsfrage hat philipp am tor
der union geschadet
mit seinem verhalten oder schadet er ihr
gerade gut das kann man vielleicht aus
heutiger sicht noch nicht so endgültig
beurteilen das werden sicherlich die
nächsten wochen zeigen die ergebnisse
die aus der untersuchung der
bundestagsverwaltung hervor gehen ja und
insofern würde ich da einfach nur mal
vielleicht einfach noch mal ein bisschen
abwarten ein bisschen auch den blick
wieder klären
ja und jetzt nicht überhitzt zu einem
urteil kommen dass mario hatte noch gar
nicht auf dem tisch liegen bei yoga sie
wollten sich dazu äußern
ja eigentlich zu ihrer frage ja keiner
was sagen weil sie glaube ich äpfel und
birnen verwechselt haben
mit einem loch ist dass ich natürlich
mit der sorge ist da ist die deutschen
selbst
der politikberatung bin ich das jeder
ernstzunehmenden lobbyist in berlin
aber das lobbyregister würde weder einen
voralarm regeln doch vermeiden
es geht hier nicht um ein hobby sondern
um meine politik skandal und ein
lobbyregister dürfte ein politiker auch
nie eingetragen werden
bei männern versucht in der lobby
register eingetragen zu werden dann
müsste die politik verlassen
wechselseitig also bei der deutschen
gesellschaft für politikberatung müssen
sie aussteigen wenn sie politiker werden
und sie dürfen nicht ein brett man sie
politiker sind wir brauchen eine
registrierungspflicht die weit über das
heutige hinausgeht für hatte womit sie
ihr geld verdienen wir geld verdienen
und wo für sie das tun und wir brauchen
zweitens für alle die
interessensvertretung betreiben ein
lobbyist darum dass mixa damals an
früchten sein warum der bundestag das
mehrfach angekündigt aber nie gemacht
hat weiß ich nicht wir als branche
kritisiert gut also ich habe tatsächlich
nicht äpfel mit birnen verglichen oder
beides verwechselt natürlich geht es
hier in erster linie um das thema
nebenbeschäftigung nebentätigkeit weil
philipp am tor aber das wort
der bereich lobbyregister das thema
kommt auch immer wieder auf in dem
zusammenhang wird ja auch gefordert
eines einzuführen
da hat ja jetzt mallorca auch ziemlich
deutlich dafür plädiert darin dabei
ihnen wahrscheinlich offene türen ein
diese dieses lobbyregister geht ja so
als wunderwaffe um solche unwuchten in
der sag ich mal ganz vorsichtig im
verhalten von politikern möglichst
einzudämmen versprechen natürlich
vielleicht dazu viel davon wenn man
dieses lobbyregister einführt naja das
lobbyregister da hat der kollege jörg
albrecht das betrifft eben die
lobbyisten und nicht die politiker aber
dass lobbyregister dass die tiere nicht
mit den politikern natürlich das lobby
register wird nicht alle probleme lösen
es ist eigentlich eine ganz unaufgeregte
sache ich verstehe auch gar nicht die
furcht vor diesen lobbyregister sehen
sie ich bin abgeordnete der linken
ich bin nun dafür bekannt dass ich zum
beispiel die deutsche bank oder facebook
öfters kritisiere ich treffe mich aber
auch mit denen ich mache das öffentlich
auf meiner homepage ich veröffentliche
sogar mein steuerbescheid keiner meiner
wählerinnen und wähler wirft mir vor
dass meine entscheidung durch die
deutsche bank bei einfluss sein weil das
kann man einfach sehen und dass ich
häufiger gegen die interessen der
deutschen bank stimme insofern verstehe
ich nicht warum man sich da werd wir
brauchen auch den sogenannten
legislativen fußabdruck dass man
nachvollziehen kann wie gesetzentwürfe
zustande gekommen sind und dass man dem
lobbyregister eben entnehmen kann welche
finanziellen interessen dahinter stehen
aber hier geht es ja erst einmal um uns
als politikerinnen und politiker und es
ist nun mal so dass ich kaum erklären
kann auf der straße dass eine
kassiererin in deutschland wegen das
einstecken eines pfandbons gekündigt
wird aber man kann eben aktien optionen
besitzen für diese firma lobby auf dem
briefpapier des bundestages machen ist
ein junge aus torgelow auf einmal nach
sankt moritz fliegt und muss sich nicht
erklären das geht nicht
verschickte jetzt schadet ja den
eindruck dass die unionsfraktion die
einzige ist die gegen die einführung
eines solchen lobbyregister ist haben
sie das vorhin gemeint mit dem satz dass
da wieder mal ein altes pferd geritten
wird genau genau das habe ich gemeint
und ich will an dieser stelle schon noch
mal an den wert des freien mandats
erinnern
und im übrigen was würden wir denn mit
einem lobbyregister ändern also damit
würde man weder kontakt aufnahmen
verhindern
doch würde man im idealfall eine
bestimmte entscheidung verhindern aber
wozu führt es am ende ist führt am ende
zu einem erheblichen verhetzung spot
enzian und es führt zu spekulationen was
könnte das eventuell bewirkt haben dass
die sich getroffen haben oder dass es da
eine verbindung gibt und das wiederum
geht auf kosten unserer demokratie wir
brauchen den austausch wir brauchen den
austausch auch in vertraulicher
atmosphäre ja um am ende auch eine gute
entscheidung zu treffen
und ob wir als abgeordnete dazu imstande
sind das entscheidet natürlich unser
persönliches format da sind wir jeden
tag selbst gefragt ja objektiv mit den
informationen umzugehen uns nicht kaufen
zu lassen
aber wird das verletzungs potenzial
nicht umso größer je weniger ein solches
register vorhanden ist verhindert das
nicht gerade das verletzungs potenzial
man kann es so oder so sehen aber worum
geht es denn hier im wesentlichen es
geht darum mit einem lobbyregister ein
gefühl zu beseitigen politiker haben in
der regel ein schlechtes image
ja und man versucht politischen haken
dran zu machen wie so oft und zu sagen
so jetzt ist alles geregelt aber im
grunde genommen glaube ich müssen wir
schon darüber reden wie viel vertrauen
bringen wir unseren volksvertretern
entgegen was trauen wir ihn zu was
erwarten die von ihnen im übrigen ist
jeder von uns da auch gefragt in seiner
persönlichen arbeit in seinem auftreten
in seiner wahlkreisarbeit über
politische arbeit zu informieren und
nicht nur wir müssen das tun in den
schulen muss es geschehen was macht ein
politiker wie sieht der alltag aus ja
das ist nicht nur glitzer das ist ganz
ganz viele klinken putzen ganz viel
bodenständigkeit und das wünsche ich mir
manchmal mehr auch in der öffentlichen
debatte
ein argument das ich sagen es geht darum
aufzuzeigen was einen politiker wirklich
tut uns klinken putzen dann würde mich
doch sehr stark ihre haltung dafür
interessieren ob philipp am tor
denn jetzt klären sollte und auch
öffentlich machen sollte was er für
diese firma getan hat naja wonsheimer
ich denke schon dass über das berufliche
schicksal von kollegen nicht die presse
zu entscheiden hat ja also dazu gegeben
zum glück in einem rechtsstaat
dazu haben wir ganz klare regeln auch im
deutschen bundestag und dazu befasst
sich im moment auch die
bundestagsverwaltung mit diesem fall und
ihre aufgabe ist es da natürlich dran zu
bleiben nachzuhaken und die
informationen einzuholen
aber ich möchte doch bitte die prüfung
solcher sachverhalte gerne durch
behörden sind dagegen sie sind also
dagegen dass er am tor erklären muss was
er für diese firma getan hat und was er
dafür bekommen nein das bin ich nicht er
hat ja auch eine erklärung abgegeben
aber ich finde es schon es ist schon
jetzt auch an der sache einfach mal
aufzuklären was steht dahinter das prüft
gerade die bundestag soll ich weiß nicht
warum das jetzt hier in abrede gestellt
hat öffentlich geschieht oder wollen sie
das hinter verschlossenen türen machen
also ich denke ich wüsste nicht was
dagegen spreche solche ergebnisse am
ende auch in der öffentlichkeit
zugänglich zu machen
da wir noch einen aspekt mallorca darauf
nehmen ich glaube alles kommt auch aus
der unionsfraktion das argument
ein lobbyregister oder eine regelung
dieser kontakte zwischen lobbyisten und
politiker würde zum teil das freie
mandat erheblich beeinträchtigen es gibt
so ein fraktionskollege von forschungs
gesagt quasi es muss ich gesicherte
räume geben wo eben transparenz nicht
verloren hat in dem der abgeordnete
sonst sein freies mandat nicht ausüben
kann
das ist auch ein argument gegen die
einführung eines solchen lobbyregister
also bei allem respekt vor schenke ich
bin selbst ein als schwarzer aber ich
muss ihnen hier widersprechen
es würde bei der bevölkerung bei den
menschen in dem land bei den medien sehr
viel helfen wenn lobbyismus aus dieser
dunkelheit herauskommt wir sie die ihm
dunkle die man nicht sieht und das mögen
wir selber nicht es gibt ein
ordentliches transparenz register in
brüssel daher die masse der im
europäischen parlament war wird sicher
besser als ich kennen
es gibt ein lobbyregister in frankreich
ruhig registriert wenn weil ich auch im
pariser büro habe es gibt sogar in
österreich ein verpflichtendes
lobbyregister das allerdings nur bedingt
funktioniert im grunde genommen gibt es
sehr viele interessensvertretung mit
einfluss auf den gesetzgebungsprozess
und mit einfluss hat die verwaltung um
das soll man dem bürger auch sagen
ich stehe da gibt es bereiche die
vertraulich bleiben müssen stichwort
insider trading alles klar
aber die tatsache dass ein update zum
deutschen bundestag mit einem vertreter
der deutschen bank über einen
freiberuflichen lobbyisten der wir einen
deutschen mittelständler unterwegs redet
das soll man wissen dass soll man diesen
dürfen noch einmal nach jena das hat mit
dem fall überhaupt nichts zu tun
erwartend ist ökologie ist solche auch
nicht werden als abgeordneter zum
deutschen bundestag dem nicht gerecht
das hat der bundestag juristisch zu
prüfen und zu beginn fällt meine private
meinung ist aber ich sage sie auch gerne
übers fernsehen und genehmigten rom
zweimal recht das ist nicht ordentlich
gelaufen was abenteuer gemacht aber
listig fehlerhaft war
das steht mir mich zu bewerten politisch
also schwerer fehler
gut also dass lobbyisten mit abenteuer
insofern etwas zu tun als in diesem
lokal kister dann ja auch die kontakte
zwischen politikern und lobbyisten
aufgeführt werden auch zu dem
unternehmen für das amt möglicherweise
schon aktiv war hatte sie ein solches
register wenn es denn verabschiedet wird
vom gesetzgeber das muss ja auch das
wichtigste ist ja es muss transparent
sein und diese transparenz muss
belastbar sein
jetzt ist die frage wie setzen wir da
die grenze wird er denn auch ein
gespräch zwischen uns beiden bei einer
tasse kaffee im reichstag festival und
drüben damit aufgeführt werden müssten
sie das dann auch angeben oder muss das
eine gewisse schwelle von bedeutung
haben und wo setzt man wieder an wo ist
da die grenze wie muss man sich das in
der praxis vorstellen und ich weiß nicht
was ziemlich lobby ihren möchten
sozusagen beim kaffee für phoenix aber
ich denke dass die ausnahmetatbestände
dass er angesprochen da gibt es eine
etablierte auch internationaler
standards dazu also
das wirklich besonders geschützte
lebensbereichen zum beispiel betrifft
und ich will das ja noch mal sagen also
heran tor ist ja mitglied der cdu die
für sich in anspruch nimmt eben auf
konservative werte zu stehen und ich
finde es geht ja einfach ein stück weit
um republikanischen anstand ja also dass
man klar macht dass man hier der
bevölkerung zu dienen hat im parlament
und die derjenige welcher spekulation
lehrt dass sie nicht diejenigen die ein
lobbyregister fordern sondern das ist ja
am tor selbst weil er nicht aufklärt was
dort stattgefunden hat es gibt dort eine
firma die irgendwo in delaware
registriert ist die hat eigentlich kein
produkt die hat eigentlich gar nichts
also ich habe ja auch meine zweifel an
einem businessplan wenn man ein
expertengespräch mit an die shoah zu
künstlicher intelligenz führt aber das
nur nebenbei
aber da muss wirklich am tor ihres
aufklärung leistender ist er in der
bringschuld und das lobby register das
ist die aufgabe des bundestages und zwar
damit einfach solche
entscheidungsprozesse nachvollzogen
werden können und das ist auch überhaupt
nichts aufregendes sondern das ist eine
ganz langweilige geschichte damit
bürgerinnen und bürger nachvollziehen
können mit wem ich mich zum beispiel
getroffen habe und dann können sie ab
gleichen wie zum beispiel meine
entscheidung ausgefallen sind und ich
wüsste nicht wo das irgendwelche
spekulationen werden sollte er uns aber
jetzt gibt es auch noch andere bereiche
die da eine rolle spielen dass wir zu
tun haben das stichwort
nebenbeschäftigung dass hier schon
gefallen nebeneinkünfte da gibt es ja
auch regelungen eine ganze reihe von
abgeordneten haben zum teil erhebliche
nebeneinkünfte sie müssen zb
unternehmensbeteiligungen erst ab 25
melden
auf diesem gebiet muss der bundestag
auch schärfere regeln einziehen auch im
sinne von transparenz und dass die
bevölkerung sieht wofür abgeordnete die
ja von ihnen gewählt wird gewählt werden
dann auch stehen und wovor aus welchen
quellen sie sonst noch einkünfte
beziehen und nicht nur als abgeordneten
ja ich denke transparenz ist genau das
richtige stichwort
das gilt zum einen für billig am tor
denn ich denke er kann diesen vorwürfen
wirklich nur mit maximaler transparenz
begegnen um auch vertrauen wieder zurück
gewinnen und selbst der kommissarische
landeschef der cdu in mecklenburg
vorpommern rehberg hat das ja bei uns
bleibt am montag auch gesagt dass das ja
viele fragen offen seien
wir hoffen dass er diese fragen
beantwortet unabhängig davon denke ich
dass die hoffnung auf größere
transparenz auch bei diesen debatten um
nebenbeschäftigung eine rolle spielt ich
denke aber da muss man natürlich
aufpassen was was dann auch tatsächlich
veröffentlicht werden kann
und ich denke dass abgeordnete generell
auch im leben weiterhin verankert sein
sollten um auch politische
entscheidungen zu treffen
generell denke ich wäre während
detailliertere angaben sicherlich besser
ich glaube nicht dass es dafür momentan
eine mehrheit gebe im bundestag wo es
ist mehr transparenz geben für
abgeordnete was sie zum beispiel noch an
nebeneinkünften haben einer
nebenbeschäftigung oder reicht das aus
was wir bisher an regeln also ich finde
die regeln die wir jetzt vertrauen spa
renz haben sind wirklich ausreichend und
im übrigen schützt auch transparenz
nicht vor fehlern
das muss man auch ganz klar sagen und
nicht warnen oder vor wenn der jetzt
beispielsweise ein lobbyregister damit
verknüpfen zu sagen dann können wir die
entscheidung des abgeordneten besser
nachvollziehen genau darin liegt ja der
fehler nur weil ich mit dem oder dem
oder dem spreche heißt das ja nicht dass
das nun am ende meine entscheidung
hervorgerufen hat also noch einmal wir
spekulieren hier der stochern im dunkeln
es wird versucht regelungen aufzustellen
mit denen man entscheidungen
nachvollziehen kann warum fragt man die
leute nicht einfach was soll das warum
warum versuchen wir nicht einfach eine
andere kommunikation an den tag zu legen
als an einem einzelfall jetzt wieder
regeln zu diskutieren die am ende alle
treffen und wo völlig unklar ist ob das
überhaupt was bringt
die muss man das dann einschätzen diese
ganze die transparenz es gibt ja nicht
nur wirtschaftsstarke
lobbyisten es gibt auch umweltverbände
menschenrechtsorganisation auch die
haben lobbyisten sie haben auch
interessen zu vertreten auch die haben
viel kontakt mit mit abgeordneten das
muss ja dann auch alles in ein solches
lobbyregister rhein ist da tatsächlich
noch viel potenzial vorhanden an
transparenz muss ja noch sehr viel
offengelegt werde in alle richtungen
absolut also das darf keine transparenz
aller card geben ich denke auch andere
verbände müssen sich diesen regeln fügen
ich will ja noch einmal sagen man kann
einem abgeordneten ja nur eine frage
stellen die studios käuflich wie ist
deine entscheidung zustande gekommen
wenn ich weiß mit wem er sich getroffen
hat ich mache das öffentlich ich bin nie
opfer solcher spekulationen gewesen
deswegen verstehe ich die ganze furcht
nicht und ich will sagen natürlich
bräuchten wir auch weitergehen oder
button ich finde zum beispiel dass wir
auch ein verbot von parteispenden von
unternehmen brauchen das würde uns im
übrigen auch ersparen dass wir eine
wettbewerbs ungleichheit haben im
politischen wettbewerb weil eben
bestimmte parteien die industrie
entscheidung treffen dann mehr zuwendung
bekommen es würde uns materialschlachten
in wahlkämpfen vielleicht etwas auch
reduzieren
und ich denke hier ist noch viel luft
nach oben in deutschland was meinen sie
das ist völlig weltfremd das ist eine
völlig weltfremde vorstellung
weil also entschuldigung da muss ich
nicht darüber diskutieren also sie
wissen selber wie sich wahlkämpfe
finanzieren wie wollen sie das sonst
alles finanzieren das brauchen sie wir
haben glücklicherweise auch noch andere
finanzierungsoptionen es ist ja zum
glück nicht so wie in amerika bei uns ja
aber also dass in einen zusammenhang zu
bringen
parteispenden im wahlkampf mit unseren
entscheidungen dass das also dass wir
quasi käuflich sind das ist also das
verbitte ich mir so eine unterstellung
ja wir treffen die unternehmen also das
genau ist wohl die überzeugung aus
überzeugung weil wir der meinung sind
wir brauchen eine gesunde wirtschaft
damit unser land am leben erhalten wird
damit wie ein gutes soziales
sicherungssystem zum beispiel haben ich
will aber gestatten sie mir vielleicht
diese anmerkung dann doch noch mal
machen
ich kritisiere dass wir generell ein
sehr schwieriges verhältnis zum thema
interessenvertretung in deutschland
haben
also ganz ehrlich wenn wir abgeordneten
keine verbände hätten keine unternehmen
hätten niemand hätten der draußen in der
praxis wie erfahrungen mit den gesetzen
macht die wir beschließen
dann werden wir ganz am anfang also wir
brauchen natürlich auch ratgeber von
außen das ist ganz wichtig und auch da
muss ich was in der debatte ändern dass
lobbyismus das interessenvertretung gut
und richtig ist und natürlich auch
bestandteil unserer demokratie ganz ganz
wichtig es ist doch ein unterschied ob
ich einen finanziellen vorteil daraus
habe es ist überhaupt nicht verwerflich
dass ich auch philipp am tor zum
beispiel für technik interessiert das
ist doch nicht das problem
oder dass er sich mit einem unternehmen
trifft das problem ist dass er einen
finanziellen vorteil in anspruch nimmt
und das ist ein knallharter
interessenkonflikt das heißt lobbyismus
ist er eigentlich eigentlich auch sehr
positiv zu sehen
es gehört zum zum spiel der demokratie
zudem zur interessensvertretung zur
entwicklung von politischen projekten
von politischen vorhaben auch dieser
lobbyismus dazu ist diese diskussion die
wir immer führen im zusammenhang mit
lobbyismus in so etwas wie mit am tor
passiert ob es jetzt nur direkt auf
lobbyistenregister betrifft oder nicht
aber dass dieser dieses diesem
schlagwort kommt immer wieder auf ist
das etwas was letztendlich dann auch der
politik schade dass wir das immer so
negativ definieren lobbyismus
also da muss man jetzt verschiedene
seiner ersten mal gerne
interessensvertretung ist ein
kernelement der demokratie und
lobbyismus ist die systematisch
von interesse wenn ich aufhöre mit der
interessensvertretung wenig optimismus
verändere dann ende die demokratie wenn
es keine interessen mehr gibt die jemand
verdreht ist vorbei mit der demokratie
also wir brauchen den lobbyismus volle
zustimmung zur frage nach einer
zustimmung zur fragen zum thema
parteispenden eine politische partei
finanziert sich aus drei quellen
staatliche förderung mitgliedsbeiträge
und spenden wenn ich die spenden ab 3
oder reduziere dann muss ich entweder
die stadt und ihre förderung erhöhen
das will niemand weil die parteien in
deutschland ist schon so viel regen oder
moz die mitgliedsbeiträge erhöhen das
bild lässt sich auch niemand also es
muss diese dreiteilung zu lassen
klar ist dass man spenden ab die wissen
mit regen das ist ja auch so vorgesehen
veröffentlichen muss so dass man hinweis
welches unternehmen gibt welcher partei
entgelte um im lobbyismus minister muss
im grunde genommen natürlich nicht dass
drinstehen was vertraulich sowohl im
französischen wie im größeren register
gibt es auch an vertraulichen teil dem
was er nicht für medien zugänglich ist
weil es ja auch delikate vor endlich
erwähnte schon das wort insider trading
aber die gewohnt sache dass jemand für
einen bestimmten konzern unterwegs ist
und sich bemüht für diesen konzern
deutliche regelungen in ein gesetz oder
eine juristin der zu kriegen ist in
ordnung
da muss ich halten
es ist zu sagen da ich eine empfehlung
an die forschung es würde schon sehr
helfen wenn man bei gesetzestexten die
sich im bundestag ändern in den
gesetzesmaterialien lesen könnte warum
eine einer dicke ein paar grad geändert
wurde
und wenn von außen her and text
übernommen würden würde ich es für klug
halten das aufzuschreiben externer text
das ist ja keine schande dass sich der
deutsche bundestag und derivate zu
regeln
inter finanzmarkt industrie gespräch
sucht sehr vernünftig sogar wenn nicht
jeder abgeordnete weiß über derivat
berichtet aber es wäre hilfreich wenn
man in den gesetzesmaterialien nachlesen
könnte der warum diesen text geändert
hat das heißt lobbyismus ist hilfreich
aber transparenz ist eine unabdingbare
voraussetzung herrnsheimer in der
politik ist auch in einem demokratischen
staat ist viel macht und auch viel geld
unterwegs die politik muss gestalten sie
muss viel auf die beine stellen die
bürger erwarten viele aktivitäten wo
auch wie gesagt das ist ja gerade
milliarden von euro unterwegs sind
investiert werden
überall dort wo geld ist ist natürlich
auch eine gewisse anfälligkeit
verkäuflichkeit für korruption
wie kann denn die politik oder durch
solche maßnahmen und durch welche gesten
vielleicht kann sie denn auch diesen
vorwurf von käuflichkeit am besten
ausweichen um klar zu machen wir gehen
mit dem geld der bürger anständig um
hier wird vor allen dingen sachbezogen
ergebnisorientiert gearbeitet
durch kommunikation ganz klar
und die fehlt in diesem fall am tor ist
reicht halt nicht für instagram post
abzusetzen auf die fragen der spiegel
journalisten nicht zu reagieren
auch weitere medien anfragen nicht zu
reagieren und dann zu hoffen dass man
schon irgendwie durchkommen das sorgt
dafür dass menschen wählerinnen und
wähler frustriert sind von dem was sie
dort erlebt
dann erleben sie andere cdu politiker
die herren am tor verteidigen also in
diesem fall glaube ich hilft nur
kommunikation und aufklärung ganz
generell denke ich dass politiker so
viel informieren sollten wie sie können
ich finde dass das viele politiker auch
sehr sehr gut machen indem sie zum
beispiel neben den klassischen medien
auch auf die sozialen medien setzen dass
die frage runden veranstalten also dass
sie sozusagen gleich bar sind auch für
kritische fragen und ich glaube dass das
eigentlich in deutschland auch im
vergleich zu anderen ländern ganz gut
funktioniert umso wichtiger dass bei
skandalen und das bei fragen möglich
restlos aufgeklärt wird damit kein
bleibender schaden am ende entsteht und
welche sorgen müssen wir uns denn um die
zukunft von philippe am tor machen kann
er dennoch landesvorsitzender werten in
mecklenburg vorpommern jetzt steht die
neue valiant wissen sie in der politik
ist immer alles im fluss sie können
heute nicht sagen was morgen ist und
insofern werden die nächsten tage und
wochen
diese frage beantworten übrigen habe ich
die selbst auch nicht zu beantworten
sondern die cdu mitglieder im
landesverband mecklenburg vorpommern
aber ich bin mir sicher der philipp wird
ob in der politik oder anderswo in
seinem leben seinen weg gehen und ich
ist ein sehr talentierter junger mann
und hat ein super abschluss als das ist
die beste voraussetzung um im leben
erfolgreich zu sein ein 27 jähriger
junger kollege berlin hat die maße darf
der als politischer rock'n'roller noch
möglich stränge schlagen kann man ihm
das nachsehen
klickt dann die zweite chance das muss
jeder für sich selbst entscheiden und
das müssen die wählerinnen und wähler
auch entscheiden er hat in eine firma
sozusagen sein politisches kapital
investiert die sich mit
gesichtserkennung beschäftigt hat ich
hätte ihm empfohlen vielleicht auch in
einen spiegel zu investieren in denen
morgens gut hinein blicken kann
das ist das beste politische kapital und
ich bleibe noch einmal dabei ich bin
auch für ein verbot von parteispenden
unternehmen bernie sanders hat in den
usa gezeigt man kann auch kleine beträge
einsammeln von bürgerinnen und bürgern
und trotzdem mehr geld und unterstützung
damit generieren als andere
viele parteien meine partei wir
verzichten auf parteispenden von
unternehmen wir stellen uns auch den
politischen wettbewerb
und das ist die politische kultur die
ich mir in deutschland wünsche was sie
jetzt auch überfordern
besteht nicht die gefahr dass man sagt
also die politiker die müssen da ganz
sauber sein dass müssen eigentlich
besseren menschen sein dass müssen
vorbilder sein für alle
der vater hat man da nicht die politiker
denn ungenauigkeiten schummeleien aller
art die gibt es ja auch noch woanders
gibt es nicht in der politik
ich behaupte doch nicht dass ich mein
heiliger bin ich bin auch schon ein
betrunkener aus der kneipe gefallen
sondern es geht darum dass meine
entscheidung wo ich mit einer besonderen
macht befugt bin die mir die bevölkerung
in einer wahl verliehen hat dass ich
damit sauber umgehe
das heißt ich kann mich irren natürlich
kann ich auch einen fehler machen
ich kann auch schlechte entscheidungen
treffen und ich bin nicht unfehlbar aber
das ist einfach notwendig um einen
vertrauen herzustellen und ich glaube
auch dass die bevölkerung durchaus auch
sagt es gibt politiker die machen einen
harten job
die wollen gar nicht mit denen tauschen
aber dann muss man sich diesen respekt
auch verdienen und dafür darf man keine
geheimniskrämerei veranstalten new
yorker wenn es jetzt vorerst keine lobby
register gibt es war ja ich habe es
vorhin schon mal gesagt wurde ja bei der
letzten bei den letzten
koalitionsverhandlungen zwischen spd und
union schon mal aufgesetzt kamen dann
wieder aus dem koalitionsvertrag raus
wie werden eigentlich dann die
lobbyisten die vertreter ganz
unterschiedliche interessen verbände
reagieren vor allen dingen wenn dann
immer wieder dieser verdacht aufkommt da
wird liegt am anfang formuliert habe da
in einer dunkel zone gemauschelt und da
sei alles gar nicht transparent wie weit
schädigt das
auch ihren berufsstand also unser beruf
dann seite darunter daher würden wir es
gerne ändern aber an bord ist der
bundestag und sind nicht wir
wobei man dieses thema spenden da möchte
ich dem land in asien auch einmal
widersprechen das muss man breiter sein
da geht es nicht nur um die spenden an
den verein sondern zum beispiel auch an
die spenden hat die ngo s also so wie
ich glaube dass man ab einem gewissen
betrag spenden an parteien
veröffentlichen muss sollte man spenden
an endlose ab einem gewissen betrag auch
veröffentlicht strich zu weil das wäre
ein beliebtes lobbyismus spiel
das sage ich bin eine insel ich mache
nicht lobbyismus sondern advocaat sie ja
ich bin finanziere mich aus spenden aber
die spender nicht dann kommt man darauf
dass eine umwelt
die sehr viel lärm gemacht hat zum thema
dieser von einem autokonzern tech handys
erzeugt finanziert wurde
danke an faz und bild etwas aufgedeckt
haben aber das gehört auch gesagt wir
wollen dass solche dinge gesagt werden
wir wollen sind nicht verbieten der die
musik vielleicht sollte die linke
politisch das eine oder andere händen
dann und dann würde man ihnen auch was
spenden aber in bringt sie sei es dass
bürger wissen damit darauf das gefühl
hat es geht ordentlich zu aber die
sammelt und die spende als gäbe es keine
wahlkämpfe mehr gleiches überreicht
us-vertreter und ohne
interessensvertretern ohne überall
kämpfen haben wir keine demokratie mehr
und diese dinge kosten geld aber ich bin
stolz dass wir keine spenden von wem der
deutschen bank bekommen deswegen will
ich da gar nichts ändern aber ich stimme
ausdrücklich zu auch umweltverbände
müssen klar machen wenn es dort
finanzkräftige interessen gibt da gibt
es überhaupt kein widerspruch sein
was glauben sie denn jetzt diese
diskussion die wir jetzt gerade haben im
zusammenhang mit philipp amthor die
hatten wir schon häufiger es gibt eine
ganze reihe von politikern die das
unangenehm aufgefallen sind ich brauche
es jetzt gar nicht alle vortragen viele
haben sie ja auch noch in erinnerung was
glauben sie jetzt wird das problem jetzt
eher ausgesessen wird man wartet man bis
ein anderes megathema wieder kommt das
dann alles zudeckt oder wird es dieses
mal doch etwas sich bewegen weil man so
nicht weitermachen kann gerade weil im
moment ja die aufmerksamkeit der
öffentlichkeit auch ist die frage wie
geht es mit der wirtschaft weiter mit
der sozialen sicherheit vieler menschen
wird das dieses mal eine andere
sichtweise der parteien der fraktion im
bundestag erforderlich machen
ich denke zunächst bleibt es ein thema
muss um den fall am tor geht
ich glaube nicht dass dieses thema
momentan zumindest so viel kraft hat das
ist die anderen themen überwiegen würde
die menschen machen sich eben momentan
vor allem sorgen um ihre jobs
ich denke es kommt darauf an noch einmal
wie er am tor mit dem fall weiter umgeht
ob wir das weiter aussetzt ob er weitere
dinge veröffentlicht es kommt auch
darauf an ob es möglicherweise weitere
enthüllungen gibt in diesem fall und
natürlich wie die cdu sich verhält
momentan scheint es mir so als führe
härter die strategie jetzt erstmal
weiter zu machen
ich weise auch zu versuchen den
landesvorsitz trotz allem noch zu
bekommen und dann eventuell im
gleichschritt auf die spitzenkandidatur
zu verzichten
denn ein wahlkampf gegen manuela
schwesig wo ein politiker mit so
heftigen vorwürfen konfrontiert war und
so eine debatte ist das kann man sich
schwer vorstellen also wir scheint das
ist momentan seinen plan ob der aufgeht
das weiß ich nicht das bezweifle ich
auch ein bisschen denn dafür gibt es da
nicht genügend transparenz
bis zum jetzigen zeitpunkt aber dass das
ganze so viel kraft entwickelt das ist
im bundestag zu einer einem umdenken
geführt oder dass möglicherweise der
verschärfungen stattfinden das laub
nicht verschieben
letzte frage zum ende der sendung ärgert
es sie dass ein politisches talent wie
philipp an tor sich so in misskredit
gebracht hat ja natürlich absolut ich
schätze ihn sehr menschlich und insofern
hoffe ich dass alles am ende irgendwie
gut ausgeht aber es ärgert mich
natürlich ganz klar und im mittelpunkt
steht auch für mich und für uns immer
der mensch und insofern werde ich ihnen
weiterhin auch schätzen
gut dann bedanke ich mich für die
diskussion hier bei karl jurka und paul
ronzheimer die zugeschaltet waren beim
schinken die masse
danke dass sie da waren diebe zuschauer
morgen in der phoenix runde
zerstrittenes europa die schwierige
mission ist geht darum das ja
deutschland am ersten juli für ein
halbes jahr die eu-ratspräsidentschaft
übernehmen wird und da ist eine ganze
menge zu bewältigen bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]